hello congratulations you are both
something else in this film
thank you very much looking forward to
talking about your performances for many
many many weeks to come
um I wanted to start here because I've
seen the movie twice now and the line it
was like he took my voice that day just
when I was about to start finding it is
just like absolutely devastating to me
so to highlight some of the good out
there can each of you pinpoint someone
early on in your careers who who made
you feel seen and supported and helped
you take a positive step forward when
you needed it most when you were first
starting out yes I would love to I want
to throw a big shout out to Ethan Hawk
who cast me in a play when I was 23
years old and he um has been one of the
biggest Champions not just of my acting
but of my writing encouraging me to
write in all different kinds of ways you
know he's a person who really has took
me seriously before I really even took
myself seriously in some ways
um and you know I think but there I've
had so many female mentors but I never
expected to have this like Gen X dude
become like an incredibly important
Mentor for me and um you know I just
have so much love for him I love that
yeah I have one
um on my first ever job which was Pride
and Prejudice that Joe Wright directed
and I was 18 and I had never been in a
film or anything before it's my first
ever job
um and I walked into the first day of
rehearsals and I was terrified and I was
sitting on my own and Judy Dame Judy
Dench came over to me and stuck her hand
out and said hi I'm Judy
um nice to meet you I believe we have
the same agent which we do and she sat
down next to me and chatted to me until
we started rehearsals and
um and she was based she is was will
always be my idol and uh and just to
have her on day one go up to the
complete unknown random teenager in the
corner was just amazing she's always
been very supportive and lovely love
hearing good things about people I
admire uh so I know you were both able
to work closely with the real Megan and
Jody before production but then they
weren't really involved while you were
filming so of everything you knew you
were going to have to tackle in this
film was there any particular scene or
beat that became the most important
thing for you to you know I guess
discuss and analyze with them before you
jumped into filming
such a good question
I mean you know I think their book she
said is so thorough in terms of the
journalism that I had fewer questions
about that I had a lot more questions
about like the phys their physical life
um both at home like how who's providing
Child Care who's putting dinner on the
table how do you and your husband you
know juggle kids and work and and whose
career is taking the Forefront in that
moment
um and then other questions that have to
do with like how do you walk into a room
with a source you know how do you
conduct yourself physically what do you
bring into that room are you bringing
out a recording device are you bringing
out a notebook and I think for Jody at
least I think it was a little bit
uncomfortable for us to have me asking
her all these questions when she's
normally the person asking the questions
but they couldn't have been more
generous and supportive with us and
really opening their lives to us yeah
and and they were they were amazing
because we spent a lot of time with them
before we started shooting we mined them
you know we asked them so many and
specific questions you know because so
much the film is true to their
experience that to what really happens
and so I remember saying to Megan like
talk me through beat by beat how this
went down with Lanny Davis and she you
know she really talked me through what
that's that felt like and but what was
amazing is when we started shooting they
just stepped away in the most gracious
way they didn't you know they they
weren't possessive they didn't come on
set they just sort of allowed it to be
its own thing and understood that it was
going to have its own life and um and
trusted us which just was incredibly
generous all right so now for working
with each other I know your friends I
know you've worked together before but
even with all that history between you
was there ever a moment on set when you
kind of like stopped dead in your tracks
and looked at the other and said like I
knew you were really good but I didn't
know you were that good I always knew I
bought it but yeah I was just talking
about this There Was You Know Zoe has
these a number of scenes where she gets
a phone call as Jody and and
the first one we shot was I mean like
four days into filming or something it
was great it was in the New York Times
building and it was the phone call where
Ashley Judd calls
um
and you know in those scenes there's no
one on the end of the phone there's an
ad reading the lines and it's not easy
to try and you know immerse yourself in
those moments so much easier when you've
got an actor in front of you you've got
an actor on the phone but this was
literally someone reading the script
from behind a door around the corner and
Zoe's reaction on and we didn't do it to
do it once we did it seven or eight
times and every single time we did it
she was that as incredible as she is in
the film every time always slightly
different always kind of keeping it live
and
um and every time she did it I just was
like
she's the most incredible actor I just
can't believe I get to work with her so
yes 100 even though I already knew she
was amazing but like yes it was that was
incredible to witness I mean I think one
of the really beautiful things about
getting to have a friendship that it can
also be a working partnership for so
long is that
you get to appreciate your friends in a
whole new way and the way that Carrie
conducts herself the way that she goes
into every scene like I've said from in
so many interviews but Carrie's
instincts were so unerring on this from
the start and there were so many times
where I felt like I have no idea how to
approach the scene and talking it
through with Carrie helped me helped
open the door for me
um you know I just I I just felt so
lucky every day to get to look into her
eyes and have this like truth barometer
here I want to go back to that phone
call thing for a quick second Zoe do you
do you have any like I don't know like
tips or tricks for for being able to
channel that kind of authenticity and
emotion and a phone call scene when you
don't have a traditional scene partner
like that
honestly
we felt the weight of this story that
real people's lives were were sort of on
the line here
um
and knowing what it took for Ashley to
stand up and and speak her truth and go
on the record and talk to these
journalists you know it makes me
emotional just thinking about it now
um every time I read the script I cried
it it I think we feel an enormous dead
of gratitude to all of those women
um and so you know that scene it was
just about
of being present with that and knowing
what the stakes were
um I also think and it's no small thing
that being able to
hold the phone think about Ashley and
look into Carrie's eyes and hold
Charity's hand it felt like this bridge
of Sisterhood
um you know between Jody and Megan but
also between the two of us and and she
was my lifeline
all right to wrap this up here so
there's still a whole lot about this
business that needs to change but lots
of good has happened because of this
story and many others out there so in an
effort to highlight some of that what is
something that's now become like an
industry Norm that if you could go back
in time and tell your younger self when
you were first starting out like you're
always going to have this no matter what
that would make her very happy intimacy
coordinator which is just in case your
audience doesn't know it's like a person
who's there sort of like a stunt
coordinator to talk you through like a
sex scene or a scene where you have to
kiss or even a scene where just
something intimate is happening or
you're in partial undress or something
just having a person there whose job it
is to oversee that feels like a huge
difference yeah I mean it's I absolutely
wild but it didn't exist before I think
we just yeah to look back and think that
we operated and did you know and I'm
blessed yeah it's crazy so that is is
concrete and huge and I think
irreversible I I hope it is shocking to
me how recently it was that the term
intimacy coordinator came up in one of
my interviews for like the very first
time and I think it was like maybe three
four years ago and I literally never
heard about that position beforehand
yeah it didn't exist and I thank
goodness it does now I think it's it's a
huge game changer all right I think they
want me to leave so I will say thank you
for your time and huge congratulations
on the film it's exceptional overall and
you two are both something else in it
thank you very much yeah thank you glad
you enjoyed good luck with the rest of
the day